hi YouTube my name is camera chambers
and this is cameras never seen today I
am watching John Carpenter's they live
I watched the fly I thought it was
disgusting and awesome
I watched the thing it's now in like the
honorable mentions of my top 10 favorite
movies I am just very excited for a day
lip I just tweeted out give me those day
live predictions for the next 20 minutes
only ready for some John Carpenter love
action let's do it I would do this whole
episode in sand in glasses but I don't
want to suck I loved it I like I just
wonder what my movie going viewing
experience would be and I had seen these
kind of movies growing up because this
is super just like straight down my
alley like right up my up or down it
it's all my alley it's weird and it's
cool and it's not political I guess but
but I get a little bit I don't know it's
just it's very engaging I had this
really ignorant idea of older films when
I started this series unless it was like
Casablanca or Wizard of Oz is boring it
wasn't going to be entertaining and then
I started watching Young Frankenstein
and Blazing Saddles and just older films
not like crazy old but older than I was
ever going to open my mind up to and
they're just so good it starts off he's
going through a hard time and then this
fantastic beautiful man in a purple tank
top is like hey we need a place to stay
come with me and take him to kind of a
shantytown where people who are homeless
or or having a rough time in life at the
moment are staying the message of the
film really seems to be especially just
right from the beginning that everyone
is in this rat race for themselves in
their own personal gain and it's all
about consumerism and just advancing on
you know your
personal ladder which yes correct
across from the shantytown is this
Church filled with people who have a
conspiracy against the government and
they're you know they're shown to be
crazy but then the government comes and
shuts down the shanty town is like
bulldozing it over and it's very
traumatizing and sad and I hate this
scene I mean bulldozing people while
they're still in bed like crazy really
violent and you're like okay well then
maybe the conspiracy theorists are
fearing people are like on to something
tonight wrote in all caps then the film
gets interesting I wrote hullabaloo in
my notes like I literally wrote down why
all the hullabaloo over some glasses am
i a sassy schoolgirl from the 30s what
is this - the cops torched the church
and Roddy Piper finds I'm gonna call him
Roddy Piper because I don't know how to
say his name nada
madam Aida it's an odd name his
character's name so Roddy Piper finds
these sunglasses that are hidden in the
wall and he's like what why all the
hullabaloo over his glasses then he puts
them on oh gosh and at this point in the
movie was when I was obviously only oh
okay I've definitely seen reference
photos from this film like the aliens
reptile robots and the obey sign she's
an interesting actor as well he's very
laid-back I would say I think is what I
would call him just very doesn't a mote
a lot from the face but you see still
great actor his facial expressions
aren't like so like he's just huh like
it's just like very subdued that's not
how I think I would react situation but
he does then I mean he freaks out for
sure it's all very in-your-face very
creepy to think that you put on a pair
of sunglasses I didn't have one without
a beard but it's they do the same thing
thank you put on a pair of sunglasses
and then everything would completely
shift I love the color change it's black
and white color wise black and white but
also it's black and white figuratively -
like on magazines consumed like
it makes tons of em so premium-grade
[Music]
there was one part but it wrote down not
at all a problem with the film I just
thought it was hilarious he walked into
the grocery store and there's these two
robot alien skeletons talking to each
other and one of them is like and then
she served blue corn tortillas oh it's
so dated
I thought what if they did a book or two
then he starts really really attacking
the physical appearance of these robot
alien skeletons and it's so funny you
you look like your head fell off in the
cheese dip in 1957 you're okay cumin
you're fine but you knows wait I need
some both of them it's worth it so he
keeps insulting the alien robot
skeletons and he then shoots some cops
and takes their gun and he goes into a
bank and sees that there's a bunch of
alien robot skeletons and he says the
line the line Laura I am here to kick
ass and Chewbacca and I'm all ass but
then he shows them all not the subtle
carefree approach I want to take in but
yes okay good mama don't like tattletale
still the zip tie from a convention so
then he makes the character of Holly
drive him to her house so you can have a
hideout and and she's at gunpoint and
she kicks the crap out of him like she
doesn't know that he's a good guy she
just knows that she's being held at
gunpoint by this seemingly crazy man and
so she throws him out a mother flipping
window
she is also out of bubblegum then I
found out the amazing purple tank-top
guy is named Frank he also has an
amazing purple sweater when you know
that a color works for you you just you
have to rock it so that's just he's
living his very best life Frank is like
hey man you got to go find a place to
hide
some a week's worth of pay which is a
lot for him because he's also very
struggling and then they start fighting
like a lot the Gulag five minutes later
Levi's choreography is amazing I also
found out that except for the face and
groin punches everything was real like
all the like the body shots and the
shows and flips and stuff that was all
full source punching each other to make
it look real
and they quarry up choreography they
choreographed it themselves and it just
was just a very immense amount of work
and an incredible display of endurance
and I love the fight but after that
entire fight brace puts on the glasses
and is like okay no you were telling the
truth let's go and they go to a meeting
for all the people who can see police
show up to that and start killing
everyone they go to the robot alien
skeleton headquarters through
teleportation you see they start telling
everyone in the robot alien skeleton
lair and you find out that they are
these like aliens who have taken over
the US and if you're a human you can
side with them and then they give you a
bunch of money I could see this stuff
happening if aliens were to come and be
like who wants money you decide with the
evil aliens people would be like me me
me let's do it and then there would be
the people who were like what's down of
hog fur fur like shedding light to
people it just it it's so well done
Holly girl from before is uh just the
worst
I thought she was best turns out to be
the worst she shoots Frank Wright my
beautiful purple sweater man the roddy
piper comes in shoots the transmitter
that is making everybody not see what's
actually happening he dies or tina city
dies in the very end and it's amazing
what other john carpenter movies have I
not seen good I need to see a male you
will wonder if anyone you know is
secretly an alien let your cat
don't do that to me yes not lots of
people will automatically call BS that
you didn't watch the movie even though
you have explained the reason since
episode 1
let's see if it's really true or not ok
let's dive into this yeah yeah no yeah
it'll make you scared to watch any media
for a few hours out of fear you'll be
privileged joke's on you I'm always
afraid if you wonder who is Roddy Piper
and why he didn't become a big 80s
action star honestly yes I know nothing
about him but I thought she was great
and his physicality like I said in that
fight scene just amazing also a weird
subtle take on acting this role that I
really enjoyed I thought really worked a
lot of sunglasses tweets and a lot of
bubblegum to it you're going to get woke
I am woke already if you will appreciate
the iconic spike scene but you'll
probably think it's a little too long at
the same time I could have done purred
double the time no that would've been
insane but I did enjoy the time actually
I did i weirdly loved it I came here to
watch movies and get actors names wrong
and I've done the names thing a lot next
week I might watch Shaun of the Dead I'm
very much still um a great kick I also
need to watch the original Planet of the
Apes I'll probably be putting up a poll
on my Twitter again this week asking
what next weeks should be thank you so
much for watching bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you